the real story for the brewers is it's a
major league debut of aaron ashby the 23
year old lefty considered the seventh
best prospect in the organization he
opened eyes in the cactus league earlier
this year feels like as with a debut a
little bit of advantage to him as well
right there
ball up the middle and it gets through
that's a base hit so contreras
with a knock to lead off the game good
start for the cubs
lying to the left field and that's a
base hit so back-to-back singles
to aboard and nobody out
right there takes the walk they are
loaded javier baez at the plate comes
with a great scoring chance
that one fair ball inside the bag at
first in the score contreras wisdom on
his heels bae is a two run single as
jack cruises into third and it's two
nothing good start for the cause
runners at first and third jake
mariznick
on the ground to short and it's under
the glove of the thomas out into left
center
jack
racing to third as baez and it's three
nothing
one away three runs in eric sogard steps
in
towards first that's gonna get us
safe
and it's all going to cub's way here in
the first four nothing
inside off the glove of narvaez all the
way to the wall in the score is
marisnick and it's five nothing
payoff pitch
and it's ball four and they're loaded
he's gonna have to take the ball from
ashby the last thing he wanted to do is
take out this young prospect before he
got through it in a call to the pen it's
gonna be miguel sanchez trying to clean
up this first inning wisdom already with
a single and a run scored in this first
inning
broken
to back alcantara
arietta on his heels an embarrassment of
riches it's seven nothing
a little cracked
right off the end of the bat he's just
got a shard left as he makes the run to
first base
and it dies a hero no balls two strikes
and he struck him out to in the inning
but the cubs score seven and they'll go
up against the veteran jake garrietta
one two pits
that's a good way to start
ureas with a base hit
[Applause]
and it's
a 3-1 ball dalvayas draws the walk
the bases are loaded james peterson will
be the batter now faces loaded 3-2 pitch
runners go way inside a tally on the
board
and now you're getting arietta in a deep
pitch count in the first inning a run is
in
peterson just continues to impress
and a swing and a miss struck him out
and arietta gets out of it he limits the
damage
bradley jr with a basic
those are having some success against
arietta
and the top of the order coming up now
luis aureus
oh that ball is hit
will watch it fly
brewers are chipping away
one home run for ureas makes it seven to
three comes don't go anywhere this one's
not over
[Applause]
that ball's ripped into the gap left
center
on his way to third goes adamus he'll
hold there
avaya's with a single
and two men are on with two outs in the
second the brewers are getting in their
licks against jake arrieta tyrone taylor
is the banner
slow roller tough play ariana pounces
throw to first and it gets by
one run is in adamus narvaez gonna keep
on trucking
and two will score
wisdom is down
a collision at first
hopefully he just got his bell wrong and
it's gonna be okay with a little time
that's always a dangerous play when i
throw sails inside a little bit with
that guy going
down the line
yeah patrick wisdom
gonna have to come out of this game
really got his bell rung there
so taylor gush you
into the game and he'll hit ninth
another
injury issue and he's gonna go to the
bullpen right here too and keegan
thompson
into the game a double switch
so it is a double switch for total
question with that knife here's peterson
a little flare center field late break
by melissa lays out can't get it
taylor the third now he turns he'll stop
there a base hit by peterson
but go ahead and run at the plate
second inning here's hiro
that's down the line oh knocked down by
sogard
in the score is taylor
gaston with a base head and an rbi
the claws are up it's a one-run game in
the second inning man good job by
kessinger starting pitchers combined
today two and a third
13 runs
on eight hits and seven walks
and adamus draws the wall
two and one taylor in the air left field
hit pretty well back onto peterson over
his head off the wall
and it's mishandled briefly in left
adama stops at third base
tyrone taylor scalds one the left it's a
double the brewers in business in the
fourth peterson at the plate facing a
left-hander brothers in the 0-1
swinger ground ball base hit right field
one run is in
tyrone taylor's gonna try and score
here's the throw home
safe
taylor slides under the tag of contreras
and the brewers have the lead eight to
seven
peterson comes through again tyrone
taylor sliding underneath the tag
and david ross says check it out and the
call at the plate is
safe
jbj at the plate a single in the
strikeout that's down base hit
here comes peterson throw goes to third
another run is in it's 9-7
this time it's jackie bradley jr with an
rbi
a one pitch oh look out almost got him
didn't get him it did
he hit him
and another run will score
what's going on out there and you're
talking about one of the best bullpens
in the national league the chicago cubs
and they are having a an awful time
throwing strikes
the shift on against yelled one-two
pitch yelled takes a call and strike
three winning over take apart the second
off
who got thrown out somebody did
and i think andy haynes tried to beat
craig counsel out there
the hitting coach
was uh hooked by the home plate umpire
and i'm guessing by this it was haynes
he's upset you don't see this very often
from the brewers hitting coach he's
about as mild battered as it gets
so two outs bases loaded here is adamus
adamus in the air right center ball's
hit well mariznick on the run and it is
up and out it's a grand slam
the first of the year for the brewers
willie and davis again
and this ballpark is lit up
what more can this guy do for the
brewers back to the top of the order and
the reason
has had a day
again that ball's hit hard in the left
center field
that one is back and it hits the wall
and goes out of here
luisa
his second home run of the day
flex on him luis
and the brewers are up 15 to seven
and now the
cup summoned their closer eric sogard
quick pitch
he gets the strikeout he's gonna throw
this ball out of play this is his first
career strikeout
dribbler
and sogard will go and take happy
helmets and that's it
for running the cubs out of the building
who would have thought and this should
do it
one of the most incredible games in the
history of this ballpark
belongs to the brewers
a phenomenal comeback win
15-7 the final
the winning streak is at eight
the lead in the division is at six
at the exact halfway point of the
regular season